gradins à perte de vue depuis le parquet
de l'ancien gymnase la perspective est
impressionnante et laisse imaginer la
taille du nouveau Prado de 3000 places
la nouvelle salle passera une capacité
de 5000 personnes les travaux à
l'intérieur du gymnase ont commencé le
28 avril juste après le dernier match
des tango on va passer à l'étape des
constructions pures c'est à dire en
passant par l'ancien tribune de presse
qu'on va découper on va pouvoir rentrer
avec une une grue des nacelles et
pouvoir démonter pièce par pièce
l'ancienne charpente et l'évacuer par
cette entrée qu'on a laissé
volontairement depuis le depuis la
construction il faut démonter l'ancien
avant de terminer la nouvelle salle une
phase critique est totalement inédite
évidemment on appréhende puisque on n'a
jamais été construit un palais de moi
j'ai jamais déconstruire un palais des
sports on a tout étudié tout il peut
toujours y avoir des surprises mais en
toute logique si le planning est
respecté on devrait pouvoir tenir notre
délai du coup pas le temps de nettoyer
les cotillons
prouesses techniques le chantier avait
une autre particularité il continuait à
accueillir le public pendant la
construction un vrai casse-tête pour
l'architecte c'est la troisième phase
importante du projet qui a commencé à
peu près il y a 15 jours maintenant sur
le fait de devenir déconstruire le
l'ancienne salle qu'on avait mangé avec
la nouvelle salle qu'on avait absorbé
avec le médecin mais par rapport au
public par contre c'est une phase un peu
plus facile parce qu'il y a plus de
public donc un moment donné le chantier
à nous là où jusqu'ici on devait un réel
cloisonnement entre les zones chantiers
et les zones d'accès du public pendant
les matchs le calendrier est serré la
Villa six mois pour livrer le nouveau
Palais des Sports juste à temps pour la
reprise de la saison des tangos